all right let's try ok let's try d 4
again I might want to go for mmm let's
see i might want to go for a catalan
that's something that i should be
looking more into ok so Queens gambit
accepted I covered a game recently on my
youtube channel with this what game was
that that was Rosa vic and nakamura
Knight f6 was played instead of e5 what
are you doing response to e5
take know about just bishop here Knight
f3 maybe I'll go at night f3 development
I might have to just not take this pawn
for a little bit yeah let's take this
one just going to be defended I might
have tricks on f7 very soon ok I'm
getting a lot of development in here
lots of development i'm going to take
with my night and then look to play to
be six and then get this pawn that's
castle first it's probably something
better that it could have been doing
let's kick this night out of there and
then maybe I'd jump into e4 in fact I'll
probably do that however what's the
story here mmm
I can't be right can it get that night
out of there if it's taken its first pin
and then win right okay this is a pin
and then a win keep this in mind pins
are pins are bad you want to steer clear
of pins but if you're finding yourself
in a pin and it's undefended that's a
problem so painting in winter ski there
the night is cooked this pond should not
have been taken
yes some people are saying in the chat
some southpark references pins are bad
mkay says mr. Oh Apple something like
that okay ah well let's get here if an
extra piece and I'm pointing right at
the King I have a rook a night in a
queen in that in a blink can be taken
out that King ruck right here just sack
first or something temple on the Queen
this has to be good there's got to be
tricks against this point very very soon
let's go here first so my queen isn't
tethered to the defense of my rook i'm
dropping pawns left and right but i'm
feeling like there's going to be
something devastating happening very
soon like a knight check right now
that's got to be right night check pawn
takes Queen out or something probably
unnecessary to sac apiece first let's
just come here I'm on this a bunch if
pawn push I maybe I could just take here
feels like there should be like a killer
shot here very very soon
um I should actually be calculated more
so it may be calculated more what about
why was I being a lazy calculator just
now I was like yeah maybe there's
something being too careless here I'm
down I'm actually down material there's
four pawns 2454 pots I pause for ponds
for the night what is going on Bishop
check
let's try this
oh man I'm gonna take the night why am I
being solely I'm being a very very this
is this is very bad very bad idea let's
just say that there is a winning
continuation somehow but this is this is
not a mindset you want to get into i'm
being very lazy right now i don't i
don't know why i just all of a sudden
became lazy um let's go here Queen
tricky mates h7 is g6 really a move that
you could play that's going to defend I
don't think it is I think I have just
enough gas to crash through against this
King just enough keep in mind my queen
recaptures and is defending my rook on
b1 so
now what a little bit of a time edge
right now just a hair now pawn takes
Queen takes rook e7 or g5 i think is
sufficient okay this is all forest brook
here or here i think both lead to no no
no no no no no no this is better
actually because there's two different
mates happening wait wait wait wait
let's look for something more forceful
check king here check now I see that
there's pretty much no defense after
this I think Queen takes rook is forced
check
King here check
check kingi a rook takes pawn check King
f7 route g7 check King has to go home
rub check to e1 and then eventually like
a queen here's mating I'm going to go
with this line because it's just more
forceful and the forceful lines are
usually easier to calculate that's
probably a bunch of different ones but I
got this in I get my other look involved
and so this is going to lead to me
probably had a quicker one there
wait is this even leading to me this
leading to me it should be where's the
main give me the mate I don't have much
time here much time ok now i can't i
figure this made out check checking my
opponent like crazy let's check here pin
city
okay check here and then me right
where's the main actually that's not me
I gotta just win this one on time after
all that what a disaster the Kings
running for the hills now I have to bail
out I have to bail out what a disaster
oh man everybody's getting on my case he
had a matin to making one and a half he
missed the matin one and a half oh man
okay oh man good game ah man let's go
back here we'll end up seeing my own
miscalculations for sure ok what's the
suggestion here maybe don't well I don't
know if I'm playing this right maybe I
should uh maybe I can think about just
pushing and then just taking that's
another line to maybe look into one
thing I could say for certain though you
can't capture this pond you got to go to
the edge you got to go to the edge that
said I don't know that your Knight has a
convenient move to make in response to
e5 now if you're playing the g4 and h3
is played you got to go here do you
really want to go there probably not so
maybe there's an adjustment already
right here before developing your king
night to its typical f6 square maybe
this is a Bertha look maybe you can look
at this but it does allow for maybe
night g5 converging on f7 with Queen h5
to follow so still I guess a little bit
tricky huh is Bishop here a better idea
or maybe a bishop in Bishop g4 maybe
maybe that's worth a look Bishop g4
Bishop e6 somehow yeah actually Bishop
g4 i think is met with queen bee three
hitting at FF seven and b7 and if Bishop
here there's Bishop takes pawn takes
queen bee three yet again and I think
you'd have to do Queen here that's a
little bit scary too what's the solution
here after a five maybe it's night here
huh struggling here i'm offering a
not-so-good advice here well what else
could you do I wonder if running with
this trade keep in mind that this Bishop
check on b4 just helps out my
development because you're helping me to
develop to pieces and you're only
getting one out when you do that I block
you take I've developed one piece and by
recapturing I've developed a second so
this accelerates my development that's
how you can maybe view that Bishop b4
move so maybe there's something instead
of that how about maybe just getting
your night out right now
night out right here I don't know
something tells me not to play this
Bishop b4 move and it has to do with
speeding up the development so maybe
something other than that but this is
always a bit awkward is it not you can't
just go to f6 and hang around there for
long because you guys have to contend
with e5 what a bug hmm that is a bug so
maybe knight c6 here I guess I'm kind of
copping out right now but uh don't go
with Bishop b4 knight c6 instead but
night g5 is a pain what a pain is this
is there something even better here
should you be going with d5 that I think
that that is a line right out you take I
take what's the computer saying anybody
have a computer fired up for these
anybody know what the story is anybody
know what the what a better setup is for
black I'm struggling here can you tell
definitely struggling
somebody's getting fired up I want some
feedback here we got air ball p firing
up ribka that's a pretty good engine huh
those of you that don't know rybka yeah
ribka you could carry a world champion
in your pocket nowadays world champ
what's the verdict here we got Houdini
fired up make sure you shut them off
during the games though you think on
your own hello Yoshi bro in the chat
what's up the setup here is that already
saying that whites better or what where
are my computer freaks I need help I'm
phone right now I'm phoning a friend if
you didn't realize I'm phoning my
Twitter followers using a lifeline on
this one Snow's art is calling up his
body Magnus getting Magnus on the line
magnus carlsen what do you have to say
here I need some closure on this I guess
I can't get away they're saying that
whites better by point 76 mm what's the
continuation for black how to complete
knight c6 oh I'm playing like ripka okay
so knight c6 and then what are they just
give me two more moves and then that's
it I just want a small short feel here
knight c6 and then what
anybody home Oh anybody i'm looking at
i'm leaning on the twitch chat here haha
windows chest tighten says Zack the
Queen Rivka calls it even with knight c6
give me another two moves knight c6 what
does white do and then what is black
deal I have an engine but it's not a
good choice to fire it up while
streaming knight c6 castles bishop e6
what knight c6 castles bishop e6 night
BD two ok so these were two moves that I
was referencing I certainly shining away
from Bishop ecigs because of captures
pawn takes and queen bee three but maybe
there's a save in Queen c8 very you
really have to know what you're doing
here on the black side maybe we could
just summarize this game like that hey
if you're gonna play e5 you better know
what you're doing cuz of chopped on
ceased for and it's easy to go wrong wow
that's why I was kind of drawing a blank
right here like I didn't know what how
do you complete your develop like right
here what do you do this is this is
tough tough solution is their solution
so anyhow what's the verdict look into
knight c6 instead of that knight c6 and
Bishop e6 apparently I of course
struggling with that one but okay um
also let's just see where I'm where I
had my opportunity for a mate somebody
pointed out where we out here where's my
mate ah see it now oh man Queen h5 you
fool Queen aged 5 and if King g8 rook
takes pawn and Queen h5 King here rook
takes pawn king f6
that would have been better okay let me
just stop it right there Queen Queen h5
is better it wouldn't been a main too
though because the King starts to get
excited about running to f6 but that's
crazy it's still winning however you
slice it but yeah I probably missed
Queen h5 being better there huh